[Música]
comiendo
a quien conoce su familia por lo que
está aquí cómo le hizo para entrar a
televisa quién es su padrino por lo cual
ya tiene un noticiero o peor aún con
quién se acostó con quién anda estas son
las cosas que escucho todos los días en
las redes sociales que vaya que son
agresivas pero a veces también ha tocado
oírlo en los pasillos sé qué gente lo
dice y les cuento de mí porque es lo que
conozco pero es con lo que pues
muchísimas mujeres tienen que lidiar
todos los días cuando tienen un puesto
importante cuando las ascienden cuando
tienen éxito yo jamás he oído que digan
ay el licenciado buenrostro que ahora es
director con quién se habrá costado para
lograrlo si nunca
pero bueno eso es lo que tenemos que
lidiar entre muchas otras cosas las
mujeres ojalá que un día esta plática
empiece de otra forma y no tenga que
hacer ese pequeño hincapié en lo que
sucede cuando una mujer le va bien
lo que mucha gente no sabe es que lo que
hacemos las mujeres que trabajamos todos
los días es partir nos el lomo es en
muchas ocasiones que tengo que reconocer
que no es mi caso tener que cuidar a los
niños darles de desayunar llevarlos a la
escuela después irse a la oficina
después regresar a acomodar los niños en
la tarde para que los lleven a su clase
de natación y después seguir trabajando
para después darle de cenar al marido
quedar bien con el marido dormirse y
volver a empezar eso es lo que a mucha
gente se le olvida que las mujeres hacen
pero estos rollos feministas y hacernos
las víctimas y luego enrollar nos con
las próximas propias teorías de lo que
una mujer tiene que hacer o no tiene que
hacer no sirve de nada hacernos las
víctimas como ya les decía tampoco lo
que sí sirve es despertarnos todos los
días ver al mundo de frente y decirle a
la gente que lo que hemos logrado es
porque trabajamos y trabajamos un show
pues yo les tengo noticias a toda esta
gente que me pregunta con quién me
acuesto me acuesto todos los días con
barack es un perrito mestizo que recogía
hace dos años es el dueño de cada
centavo de mi quincena vaya que es un
perro afortunado porque trabajo mucho
para él
y también ha hecho muchísimo para
conseguir lo que tengo es sacrificado y
no estoy orgullosa en muchas ocasiones
de eso pero es lo que hago y lo que me
hace feliz compromisos con mis amigas
una vida en pareja
muchísimas fiestas de mi familia
trabajo 15 horas al día me despierto a
las 3 y media de la mañana todos los
días y salgo de trabajar a las 9 de la
noche
he trabajado sin descanso y lo ha hecho
con muchísima pasión y por eso es que no
me pesa y por eso es que a nadie se lo
puedo reclamar
creo que si todos trabajamos así pero
sobre todo si todos nos sentimos
orgullosos de lo que hace el de junto de
lo que tiene el de junto de lo que el
compañero de al lado en la oficina ha
logrado creo que si todos nos
sintiéramos orgullosos de eso el mundo
sería un mejor lugar
soy daniel de tu vida y no sé si alguien
sabe quién soy a qué me dedico soy
periodista trabajo en televisa tengo dos
espacios de noticias uno muy temprano y
uno muy tarde me llamo danielle tengo
nombre de hombre entonces estoy
acostumbrado desde niña al bullying que
ahora recibo todos los días en las redes
sociales
soy mexicana y soy parte de una
generación que se preocupa más por
cuántos likes tiene una publicación en
una red social
a quien le enoja que la dé junto tenga
más seguidores que yo
y en muchas ocasiones eso nos hace
olvidarnos de trabajar en conjunto y de
lo que podemos lograr
levanten la mano aquí quien ha revisado
el día de hoy alguna red social facebook
instagram twitter
me lo imaginé levante la mano quien hoy
le haya hablado por teléfono un amigo
muchas menos me lo imaginé no falló como
el micrófono si hubiera fallado ya no
hubiera sabido qué hacer
levanten la mano aquí quien ha volteado
a ver hoy a alguien y le ha sonreído le
ha deseado algo bonito
y si no les creo
pero bueno soy yo muy romántico bueno se
han puesto a pensar que a esa persona a
la que le sonrieron esa persona que a lo
mejor no conoce ni cómo nos platicaban
hace un rato está atrás de ustedes les
puede cambiar la vida o mejor aún
ustedes le pueden cambiar la vida a esa
persona
en mi caso soy muy afortunada porque me
pagan por tratar de cambiarle la vida a
la gente o por ser testigo de cómo unas
personas le cambian la vida a otras
déjenme platicarles algunas historias
para que todo lo que les quiero decir
tenga un poco de sentido
en el 2012 cuando las redes sociales
tuvieron este boom en el mundo árabe se
llamó valga la repetición de la palabra
la primavera árabe que las redes
sociales fueron capaces de convocar a
las personas suficientes para tumbar
dictaduras para acabar con regímenes que
dañaban muchísimo a la sociedad y con
ello al mundo mi jefe me encomendó hacer
un reportaje como las redes sociales o
como el internet o como las tecnologías
no me digas que ya llevo 12 minutos no
van regreso el susto
cómo es que las redes sociales y la
tecnología le cambiaban la vida a una
persona común y corriente y entonces
conocí a andrew a andrea tenía en ese
entonces 15 años se acababa de enterar
que tenía dos hermanos hijos de su papá
desde luego
ella vivió en mérida y los hermanos
vivían en algún lugar del mundo no
sabíamos en donde entonces decidí hacer
una especie de documental reportaje
reality show en el que juntas fuimos
descubriendo dónde estaban sus hermanos
nos metimos a facebook sabíamos que su
hermano se llamaba igual que su papá era
lo único que sabíamos del hermano no
teníamos más datos más que el apellido
desde luego
pusimos en facebook el nombre del
hermano
fuimos depurando los que podían ser por
la edad por lo que sabíamos de ellos y
finalmente dimos con él imagínense lo
que es que de pronto una niña te escribe
un mensaje directo en facebook y te diga
hola soy tu hermana
pero el chavo el supuesto hermano pues
lo acepto bastante bien y le mando un
boleto de avión para que viajara de
mérida a la ciudad de mexico todo esto
estaba grabado y todo esto pasó en la
televisión
dos semanas después andreas se subió a
un avión sola y llego a ver a su hermano
era un tanto rizado pero bueno lo
estábamos grabando entonces no podría
tener consecuencias pues por lo menos
trágicas
él le presento a su hermana así que ya
eran tres hermanos que hacía dos semanas
no sabían que existían y desde entonces
son una familia feliz son una familia
que convive pues en una de estas
sociedades modernas porque pues eran los
hijos que el papá había tenido fuera del
matrimonio y ahora son muy felices
cuando salió este reportaje en la tele
inmediatamente empezaron a llegar a
llegar y al llegar correos de historias
así similares así que les seguimos a
esta serie de cómo la tecnología podría
cambiar vidas y de cómo una persona o un
conjunto de personas que ni siquiera se
tendrían que conocer entre ellas podrían
cambiar al mundo y así una chava que
había tenido un accidente esquiando en
agua en playa del carmen consiguió los
donadores de sangre que eran suficientes
una persona que hacía un año había
recibido un riñón y un hígado del mismo
donante logró ponerse en contacto con
la familia de él que había fallecido
también en un accidente
y nos contaron la historia otra historia
maravillosa la de era
un señor que tenía sesenta y pico años
había sido uno de los guías turísticos
en ciudad de méxico- más importantes era
políglota hablaba ocho idiomas y por
circunstancias de la vida vivía
en un cajero automático era un indigente
la vida le había jugado muy malas
pasadas y así había acabado se había
quedado sin vista se había quedado sin
mucha memoria y por medio de esa serie
de reportajes que fuimos construyendo y
por esa
pues solidaridad que sin querer se fue
armando y gracias a lo que la gente veía
en la tele logramos conseguir que la
familia de se acercara a él no
sólo eso sino que le logramos conseguir
trabajo a ahora trabaja en la
secretaria de turismo de ciudad de
mexico desde entonces lleva ya pues
prácticamente seis años
y así fuimos consiguiendo y tejiendo una
red de eso les decía solidaridad
pues pocas veces se había visto sobre
todo cuando se trataba de un reportaje
de televisión
conocí dos de los conocidos de los
familiares de todas estas historias nos
mandaban correos nos ayudaban con datos
y así pues prácticamente todas las
historias que nos llegaron empezaron a
tener un final feliz desconocidos se
volvieron conocidos y ahora siguen
teniendo relación de alguna u otra forma
todos pusieron las manos a la obra y se
cambiaron muchas realidades y si
efectivamente escuchaba yo a carlos hace
ratito y vivimos en un país con
muchísimos problemas probablemente más
que nunca la inseguridad que les digo a
ustedes en este estado tan golpeado por
ella la corrupción de la que oímos hasta
el cansancio las malas decisiones de los
gobernantes que hemos tenido
trump y sus payasadas hacia nuestro país
y todo lo que todos los días me toca dar
frente a una cámara y con un micrófono
que es cansadísimo muertos robos
secuestros
una guerra contra el narcotráfico que ni
acabó ni se solucionó y sigue teniendo
muchísimas víctimas feminicidios niños
maltratados trata de personas pero me
niego a pensar que esa sea la realidad
de todos nosotros me niego a pensar que
esa sea la realidad de nuestro país y de
los que trabajamos todos los días y de
las que trabajamos todos los días y de
las que y de los que de verdad nos
podemos decir mexicanos así que
imagínense que todos trabajáramos así en
equipo como toda esa gente que me mandó
correos y que tu hermandad o mensajes en
redes sociales y que puso un granito de
arena para que todas estas historias que
les he platicado tuvieran un final feliz
imagínense que en el perfil de las redes
sociales hubiera un tercer icono
seguidos seguidores y cuántas vidas he
cambiado o cuántas vidas se ha ayudado a
cambiar
y que todos lucharemos por que ese
número fuera más abultado incluso del de
los seguidores el de tan ansiado
seguidores que a veces ni conocemos y
que para acabarla de amolar a veces solo
nos insultan
imagínense que todos cambiáramos de
alguna medida en alguna pequeña medida
una vida
una sola vida en toda nuestra vida no es
mucho y no es muy complicado
estaríamos hablando si esto sucediera de
un auténtico cambio en el mundo todos
los días ésta se convertiría en la red
más grande del mundo en la red más
influyente en la red más poderosa en la
red más importante no tendría fronteras
no tendría vigencia no tendría límites
no tendría bases de datos robadas no
tendría a un dueño de una red social
volviéndose millonario y nosotros
dándole todos nuestros datos qué les
parece si lo hacemos qué les parece si
hoy todos nos paramos de esta silla y
pensamos a quién podemos ayudar cómo le
podemos cambiar la vida a alguien o cómo
podemos formar parte de una red que le
cambia la vida a alguien
piénsenlo y si la respuesta es y no me
la tienen que decir desde luego pero no
se tienen que inscribir a ningún perfil
no tienen que tener wifi sólo tienen que
tener las ganas las ganas de hacerlo
contrario a lo que muchas personas han
dicho aquí seguramente les han dicho en
la vida el trabajo siempre retribuye y
la paciencia siempre paga sueñen
muchísimo todo el tiempo y duerman muy
poco porque es una paradoja pero
mientras más se sueña menos se puede
dormir para cumplir los sueños
haga lo que se les antoje a ustedes
siempre y cuando no dañen a nadie no se
fijen en lo que la gente les diga que
tienen que hacer
vivan para recibir muchos abrazos y para
recibir muchas sonrisas y no para
recibir muchos likes ni más seguidores
ya cuestas de todos los días con alguien
que sean ustedes con ese alguien que hoy
fue mejor que ayer que hoy es más feliz
que ayer que hoy tiene ganas de cambiar
una vida y que nunca había tenido ganas
de hacerlo hagan muchas cosas sean
felices y cambiamos muchas vidas muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]